good evening uh I met the wonderful
Palestinian poet Mahmud daish in Paris
uh where we were both living and that
was when I was in my early 20s of course
that was very recently
uh but I wrote this first poem I'm going
to read is dedicated to him I read I
wrote it um after his death in
in at the door you greet me a rou I look
for the Shadows that might have followed
us look for the wall behind us in front
of us we sit at enquz between us it's
midnight or it's late it's morning or
its day Silence has torn our voices
Paris is cold the dark begins early plus
ituni trees losing leaves a bird with
wings growing in your hands a desire the
echo of a gunshot a river the bullet
that crossed santes you say I remember I
respond we left his book in yesterday's
dream can we go back or has the prison
come to us who are we if the Earth is
trapped in an unsigned painting where
are your eyes Palm breath passion only
Paris allows us to believe in our
metaphors we Envy those who walk pass by
us so easily they sleep in their beds as
we look for hours home is farther than
us orange blossoms Olive and coffee I
Fall to catch you you help me to your
fall one cigarette at a time you say
they always find us one Village at a
time they say it's in our house now but
it's our room even if you don't deserve
one you say listen to Beethoven and I
follow your eyes to understand your
shadow in the crowd a Homeland an absent
mother did they forget we can love a
Maria is playing you give me a poem
about a girl you loved the window fills
with evening with wound wound filled
with echo echo filled with cry I move
closer to you I wish I could sleep in
the place that sleeps deep in your soul
wish I held your mother's hand my
father's hand I wish I saw Carmel from
your eyes the girl you kissed 60 60
Winters Summers raindrops piling in our
prayers in the footsteps we are
forbidden to have the birds are coming
today you tell me the land is smaller
than the land smaller still smaller than
our movements I call your name and you
answer death you have beaten death at
its game the freedom that took you takes
you and I find the colors of our faded
map you never say farewell never cross
just cross we meet death so it doesn't
meet us we close the door think of the
Groves the verses we will write the
letter we will not send inshallah you
say AB inshallah I say yes the land
speaks
Arabic
this following poem uh is about uh all
the languages and countries that are
part of me but never forgetting where
I'm from Blue
hours in the blue hour the nigrita cries
I hide not to deceive the darkness or
myself Lita is not far from where I
stand her eyebrows her one hand I too
invisible now behind the tree behind the
night behind the cry and all I want to
know is her name and ask her have you
ever heard your heart undressing seen a
stray dog at midnight and realize he
understands this hour better than you
will understand any hour have you ever
seen yourself in every woman with your
eyes or in women with eyes more
difficult than yours have you ever
really heard your voice echoing she
offers me tea we end up drinking coffee
trying to reach the bottom of the cup
unafraid now my teeth are stained my
English failing me my Arabic starting to
make sense we are in a Fina now perhaps
we are safe perhaps we desire nothing
else but I can't stop Bowing in prayer
five times a day my country comes to me
tells me compatriota I will always find
you no matter what language you are
speaking
and I always have to end with first of
all I'd like to say well lastly perhaps
thank you so much all you brave souls
for coming through the storm to to hear
us read
tonight and I always end with this poem
even um in hopes uh of Peace
even nothing is even even this line I'm
writing even this line I'm waiting in
waiting for permission to enter the
country the house the room nothing is
even even now that laws have been drawn
in peace to discussed on high tables and
even if all was said to be even I would
not believe for even I know that nothing
is even not the trees the flowers not
the mountains or the shadow our nature
is not even so why even try to get even
instead let us find an even better place
and call it even thank
you
hocin
for
f
comp
still
for
up or
look
for
Jo
some
for
um in the following
excerpt I shall share with you a glimpse
of my journey through
painting the original
text appeared in my book titled
Palestinian art from 1850 to the
present thanks to Lona kulman for taking
the time to choose the
passages from the original
text that the reading may fit in the
time slot I was given for for this
evening visual expression is a language
that is separate from that of verbal
expression one cannot give voice to the
other nor can one be a substitute for
the
other painting proceeds from
painting just as much as
writing proceeds from
reading for me
words have always come after
painting it is never the
reverse but since images flow from one's
imagination the unfolding of which is
bound to
memory both painting and writing are
twin products of the same
memory it is the completed images
however that reawaken en my conscience
memory otherwise why would a painting's
title the only link between words and
visual form come to mind long after I
put the finishing touches to a
painting at best the title is a bridge
that allows the viewer to negotiate an
entry into the language of a painted
image it attempts no more than to sum up
or evoke certain associations with
memory be they personal or
Collective as a
child the first Contact I ever had with
painted images came from Byzantine
icons a number of
them were placed high up in a niche of
the Jerusalem home in which I was born
born one of them probably belonging to
the Jerusalem School of Icon painting
had an Arabic inscription on it years
later I was able to decipher the name of
a paternal ancestor as the man who had
commissioned the
icon icons seemed to provide my parents
with a strength I did not
understand for for them an icon was a
window through which they could gain
entry into their own interior
world as for me I was told that the
icon's niche was the place where the
Angels left their gifts during the night
preceding a church feast
day as long as I I could last I would
wait through the night to see the angel
but all I could make out in the dark was
the light of the lantern and flickering
before the icons reticent
colors as for the images the icons
represented they always struck me with a
mysterious o which left me
speechless only now do I realize why I
was told that an iconographer does not
paint an icon he writes
it according to Legend
as Christ was bearing his cross to
Calvary a woman called Veronica came
forward from the crowd and took off her
veil to wipe the sweat from the face of
The Man From
Galilee It is believed that the image of
his features was miraculously imprinted
on the
material later referred to as the
sudarium in none of the Gospel
is there any mention of such an
incident or of the woman who often
appears in European paintings wearing a
turban in allusion to her eastern
Origins and yet at the end of it the
19th century Rome dedicated a chapel to
Veronica whose name Vera Eon means True
Image on the vi Rosa in
Jerusalem the chaper replaced the
original idea which had been to
establish a missionary School in my city
of birth to teach the city's Arab
natives the Fine Art of European
painting had the school been established
it would have been the first institution
ever to teach the European painting
tradition to the Arabs of
Jerusalem but then would my father have
sent me there instead of sending me as
an
apprentice to the workshop of Khal
halabi one of the last icon painters in
The Old
City from our
roof amidst our neighbors houses in The
Old City we could also see a walled and
rectangular place that must have once
served as a water
reservoir we used to call it bur alhan
the pool of the
Inn I do not know why but I always
thought that this open space must have
been the site referred to in the gospel
of St John as bethesda's
pool according to
Legend the
wats of bethesda's pool had miraculous
healing
powers people people believed that an
angel occasionally came down to stir its
Waters and that the first person to dip
in it was
healed for
decades it was told a paralytic man had
never succeeded in being first because
he had no one to assist
him when Christ saw the man lying there
he commanded him to stand stand up carry
his bed and
walk the miracle believed to have taken
place led to Christ's condemnation by
the city's Jews for having ordered the
lame to take up his bed on a
Sabbath the place I used to believe was
betha's pool was no more than a dry
Basin for most of the
years our time I was soon to
realize was not one of
Miracles Refugee families from the 1948
War had swamped the houses surrounding
the
site
today it seems that the pool's
Basin has expanded Beyond palestine's
borders to reach wherever the countries
disinherited continue to live
all around one sees the multitudes who
have been maed by the
wars who can tell
whom not to wait for a miracle
anymore thank
you and I'll read from my novel come uh
a few chapters I read from the beginning
so I don't think it's necessary that I
say
anything um I'll just try to reach
slowly so you can
follow the snow is falling heavily and
she has already vanished from sight he
stands in the doorway contemplating her
Footprints three steps down across the
street to the left and
Away snowflakes drift in
they hit his shirt and the shells behind
him but he doesn't
BGE the air has a faint smell of moist
soil even if it can't be possible the
narrow couple street is enveloped by the
tamak density of the old city
center it has snowed all day and the
snow reaches well beyond the curb which
can be discerned only in the one
driveway that has been
cleared in front of his shoes the carpet
is wet through and a small Bank of snow
is stealing up the wall to the right
still he is hesitating she wore boots
with thick rubber soles he can make out
the rombus grooves in the nearest
Footprints soundlessly the snowflakes
pour into the prince his glass is misted
up and his hand on the doorknob is
turning white with cold he pulls the
door towards him but just before it
closes he pushes it open again across
the street the footprints are less
distinct as if she was is no longer able
to lift her boots free of the surface or
as if she dragged one leg behind a
shallow Furrow leads from one step to
the
next the building is quiet everyone else
has gone home hours ago he slowly shuts
the door turns the key and returns to
his office sits down at the desk he
pulls a thick manuscript closer it's
damp the first couple of pages stick
together in top left it's so moist that
the smothered text can be read through
through the cover page the corners curl
upwards and there's a smear of red wine
below the tile but he isn't sure whether
it was always there he takes off his
glasses hides his face in his hands
closes his eyes she hadn't need it to
she hadn't needed bring it back nowadays
one can just print another
copy for several minutes he sits without
stirring then abruptly he straightens
himself up and bangs his fist down onto
the manuscript with the hell does she
think she
is it's your choice she had said before
she got up and left of course it's his
choice who else would it be he looks at
the manuscript abruptly jumps up and
strides over to the coat rack pull his
jacket off the hanger and on the
blueprint has just been cleared
production must send it to the printers
tomorrow for the book to be launched on
May six as planned he shudd slightly the
shirt is cold and damp where the jacket
presses it against his skin it has been
written by a young man one of the
bestselling authors in the country his
fifth novel marketing has been busy for
months he goes to the window pushes the
curtain aside the snow keeps streaming
down railing the outside world in a
quivering whiteness it's the author's
Best novel by far about subject matter
is never before touched upon with an
Insight his never before revealed it'll
sell in the
100,000 he returns to his desk and sit
down world wide perhaps
Millions it's my story she had said he'd
given her the manuscript only because
she'd lived there in morens SAU in the
peace process thought she would be
interested it was already 5:00 p.m. when
she entered his office she placed the
soap pile of papers on his desk it's my
story she said first he hadn't responded
they just sat looking at each other he
ought never have given it to her it
wasn't only because she had lived there
that he had done so it didn't matter
there were too many many of those kinds
of
problems you can't own a story he said
at last aren't any stories so personal
that no one else ought publicize them
her eyes are transparent odd that he
never before noticed you can't have
experienced this he said it kindly not
as a question but as something she could
concur with and thereby end the
discussion or as something she could
contradict by offering a series of
details he knew wouldn't correspond with
reality except within her own mind it
was always like
that one can see right into her he
thought she didn't reply just kept
peering into his eyes it infuriated him
he didn't know why all he saw was her
seeing him he picks up the phone and
calls home I'll be late he explains not
again says his wife don't wait for me
I'll pick you up on the way no I don't
want you to drive into the city in this
weather it isn't safe he speaks
sincerely and he savors the sincerity in
his own own voice I'll take a capab the
kitchen staff always leave a few lunch
leftovers in the director at fridge his
wife mentions something about the
minister for social Affairs and a
proposal for integration of immigrants
that undermines the proposal she herself
has just put forward he gets up and
walks over to the window gazes out he
doesn't listen the snowflakes flutter
ceaselessly through the darkness and the
skewed light figurines drawn up by the
street lamps and the window opposite
it's his work
but suddenly it's as if it's not he has
a lecture to prepare does the universe
hold different rules for different
people if something is read somewhere it
wasn't what she said I'll be be there in
time he says when he's hung up he goes
to the kitchen and opens the fridge but
the fridge is empty it doesn't matter he
isn't
hungry before he called his wife he had
read the first three chapters it's
fiction fascinating no one experiences
this kind of thing the book begins with
the pummeling to death of an elections
Observer with a blood melding with the
dust on the African lolium a young woman
is the a of the head of the United
Nations peacekeeping mission in morona
the pages are damp and the text smed but
the words are still readable she Stills
at the desica blood without knowing that
her life is about to become another this
is when he called his wife
535 people often think they have
experienced something they haven't she
didn't answer when he asked her did
someone Hur J Mor and S it's a kind of
story only written in novels she merely
gazed at him made him feel like a fool
even though she' said nothing nor had
any expression in her eyes that could
explain the feeling he got when looking
into them fool as if it was solely his
own fault that her gaze made him feel
like a fool it's what is said to follow
further into the novel that made him ask
her he flicks through the pages
attempting to locate the scene gets
annoyed with the dampness which glues
the pages together she wouldn't think
him a fool or or would she hurt maybe it
was the word you don't speak about hurt
when talking about war and rape in
Africa but it wasn't her where is it in
the middle of the novel further back yes
she lived there he knows everyone does
or was her job she never speaks about it
or she does but in these oddly detached
phrases those two years she lived in
Mora that's all those eyes as from far
off as two years taken out of her life
then this peculiar undertone what is it
you have joy not dread he skims through
the middle chapters but still doesn't
find what he's looking
for a country I've seen go from war to
peace he overheard her say a few years
back that's exactly it no horror now he
remembers it was at the dinner for the
Albert price we all got to do our path
that's what she said and smiled eyes far
away as if it was her doing that's what
is so ridiculous he gives up searching
for the scene and instead puts the two
heaps of paper back into one he tears a
blue note off the pad and sticks it onto
the cover paper p as if she had
personally saved Mo and S he has a
speech to write and places a manuscript
in the outbox the not reading to the
printers thank
you
for
for qus
h
for
Opera Cal
bu
for
you said in one of the other poems which
you didn't unfortunately read
tonight that
uh Exile has it ways what do you mean by
that it's a little bit what Nan said and
what I said earlier is that we're Exile
affects us in really just unexpected
ways uh there are times where we think
we understand it and then something
happens and it it complet
completely uh throws us a curve and we
are
lost uh and I think in the experience of
Exile at least in my case and probably
you're you constantly you can't arrive
and that feeling of not a being able to
arrive it's just so disconcerting as a
feeling uh you were talking about that
yesterday I think uh Kamal yes
hello you were talk talking about also
being in Exile and this uh this having
to deal with having to survive in Exile
and you have also like nathaly lived a
lot of places how have you been dealing
with it and actually now you're living
in Berlin since what two weeks or
something like that since uh two days
two
days oh
yes since two days I moved to Berlin
from Monto which is in the south of
France where I went for a couple of
months to finish a series of paintings
and I ended up there for 15
years uh last year I
spent a year at the visin shafts
colleague in Berlin and I was very
inspired by the whole city so I decided
to to move there um I don't think my
kind of Exile is is like that of
Natalie um I lived 25 years of my life
in
America and I have never
had the American accent that Natalie
has and I think that tells a
lot as to
how what Exile
means because I have I have continued to
speak in Arabic
I have continued to write in
Arabic I
have
also been writing in
English
and the the work that I'm doing whether
it was in painting or in
writing uh is on the way that uh helps
me to
uh
take the uh stress or the the experience
of
Exile where in my
work I find home wherever I
go is that is that the same experience
you have that the your home is your work
is your art is your writing sure I mean
you know um to follow up with what Kamal
said our experiences are so distinct all
I mean most Palestinians have such
distinct experience
and um Kamal was fortunate to spend it
his uh up until 20 I can't remember 25
years in Jerusalem I I didn't have that
25 I left I left when I was 17 right I
was 17 I unfortunately didn't have that
but along with not having that I also
lost language and by that I mean even
English is not my first language I I I
grew up with I don't even consider I
have a mother tongue because at home we
spoke four different languages and so
even from language I was uprooted and
Americans as American as I
sound consider me to have an
accent so uh you know you're constantly
experiencing otherness according to
where you're at you know and uh but I do
feel like Kamal the idea that I have
found a certain type of home land in my
work but um I I I still am in Palestine
every year okay and I don't know how
this
relationship how this experience has
affected me uh in terms of in
relationship to
Exile uh so it's sort of a sense where
the feeling to me is and perhaps this is
poetic image that I I'm still there all
the time and yet I'm not
you know it's that's how I experience it
internally did did you ever write a a
poem which had nothing to do at all with
your history with your background well I
did write a book called love in strange
horses which was the three movements of
the
heart uh I thought perhaps love might be
a little uh less uh a less turbulent
ground I realized it was uh even more
but uh but even there uh it's what I
said earlier with with Exile even there
what's political and what I mean yes we
have political identities but how do we
Define politics because even love can be
political uh Y what do you think when
you listen to our
guests
um well first of all I think how
privileged I am
yeah uh I have a choice I have chosen to
become an international Nomad but I can
come back to the country where I was
born anytime I want um when I left my
apartment I sold it it was not somebody
else just taking it from
me um I do recognize the sense of being
uprooted uh having a cultural mixed
background my mother's Austrian and my
father half German and I recognize
growing up feeling different than the
other kids it was before immigration was
so usual in Denmark and yet not
belonging I recognize the thing of
language because we didn't speak German
at home because my parents wanted us to
be Danish so as a kid I couldn't really
communicate properly with the Austrian
part of the family my grandmother and I
learned German much later but as a
grownup I realized I always felt like an
8-year-old uh asking for chocolate when
I spoke German now that has slowly
changed in the last few years but um
it's yeah so so I do know the sense of
not belonging and since I was 23 I have
most of the time lived outside of
Denmark mainly in Africa and then New
York and various European
countries and I also recognize therefore
feeling at home in my
work and I'm at home on the road also um
what I tried to do um was at some point
because I was always looking for a home
a place where I would feel at home and
at some point I realized I won't find it
but I can make it home um and make that
feeling of estrangement also my home um
but again I wish to underline uh the
privileged of
choice do do you feel any political or
moral obligation in your
writing yes it's almost like I can't
help it
um and you can say you don't know where
it comes from when we again grow up
under such privileged conditions as we
do in Denmark um but actually it just
makes me so much more um aware of the
obligation to get
involved um like for some right now I'm
involved in working on something um with
other writers against the surveillance
uh in America yeah and I'm I'm very
aware that because various friend of
mine writers from other countries who
have written about this they suddenly
can't get entry into the US and New York
is my home and yet I
feel um if people who have a country to
go home to don't speak out against this
who should so these kind of thing I feel
obliged and maybe also you know having
grown up with this awareness always that
um the Red Cross saved my mother and
since after the second world war they
went around to the schools and simply
took the skinniest children and send
them to either Switzerland or Denmark or
Sweden to get food and my mother was 3
months in Denmark um actually Denmark
had taken 20,000 kids after the first
world war and they took 3,000 after the
second world war and I always feel
that's such an extraordinary measure
that was the Denmark that once was that
you take in the kits of your enemy and
feed them I mean that is not the Denmark
unfortunately we have known the last 10
15 years but I think it's the one we
should fight for beautiful uh nashan
nashan
um what what do you think poetry is able
of what can what can you reach or who
can whom can you reach with poetry whom
you cannot reach by activism or
journalism because you're also an
activist you could reach yourself with
poetry this is the medium which is um in
my opinion best to reach your own self
and by reaching your own self you would
find out that you are reaching others
because others are part of your own
self and that's if I just must say
something that's why I think is so
fantastic with with this uh you're
coming here and visiting us is that we
get to know this whole conflict we get
to know it from a much more deeper or
inner uh point of view which I think is
very important what do you experience or
what
what have you been feeling by meeting
each other who would like to
say actually when you was talking about
Homeland and Country and uh and
belonging and all these things actually
um my home when I meet being here with
with Kamal and Yahya and Natalie is like
being at home this is something very
rare the last time I saw Kamal was 3
years ago I guess it was in Paris and I
saw natal last time 2 years ago in not
this year actually in in New York and uh
I'm just meeting Yahya yeah now so uh
this is for me being at home because um
in Palestine those three of them are not
allowed to come and back and live in
their country so being with them is the
country for me do you feel isolated yes
not isol I'm exiled because exiled in
Jerusalem the fact that you remained in
your Homeland while the majority of your
nation is exiled and prevented from uh
coming back and exiled by by by by force
by by the Israeli occupation so uh of
course we we I'm living as exiled and
whenever I'm reading uh literature or
theoretical things about Exile I do feel
that
they do work well with me m but still do
you have any uh feeling of similarity
with us with your Danish colleagues is
it although you have another experience
and you have other conditions is there
still something in common and Common
Ground
actually nationalities are labels take
the labels we are very similar so
uh these are just labels and these are
just uh slogans and titles just take
them and you would find out that we are
very similar and we have
uh so the S and the other are also
Illusions so personally I'm always feel
that I'm the other of course there is
those cultural things cultures are
different the way of expressing uh
intimacy is difference different for
example they would say that oh
Scandinavians are
cold this is not true comparing to Latin
Americans for example or Middle Easterns
which we are very much good in
expressing feelings but intim the
difference is in the way of expressing
the intimacy I think scand Scandinavians
are very intimate but in their own
way um
now you read actually some of your
colleagues Danish colleagues text us
what do you think of them not if they're
good or bad or anything but what is your
uh uh experience with these texts are
they are they very much different than
the text from Palestinian
writers uh as text you mean yeah SE yeah
in poetry there is a difference and for
example um I like the work of Martin
who's not with us unfortunately because
of the storm uh but for example the work
of Yahya even he's both are writing in
Danish yeah I could see the difference
it has to do with um with with the whole
uh history and whole context and whole
experience so we are different in
literature in what we are writing and
this is the beauty of literature because
imagine if we would all would write uh
text with the same taste yeah this would
be the hell yeah do do you get inspired
by by us yeah and although they're again
they're different because we're dealing
with different um cultural and
Linguistics uh differences but actually
it's still always about the human
condition and I think ultimately when
we're reading that's the beauty of
literature or I like to believe art that
we transcend so much of those um borders
and boundaries that we create
um sort or the political uh structure
create for us and I was speaking to a
journalist before uh in saying that you
know we focus so much on difference all
the time and we don't look enough on
common on commonalities and once we
start becoming aware of the other that's
the commonality surface and ultimately
we just realize like nean said the
labels are gone and just the The Human
Experience is what comes um I mean we
were together uh all all day and I felt
like I was uh I had known her for a long
time and when I was speaking with you
yesterday we were strolling the streets
it didn't feel like the first
time it didn't feel like the first time
we were strolling those streets yeah
yeah yeah do you want to say something
about well well just just to add that
for me also I feel the same way I think
what is always part of the respect for
other human beings is you have to
recognize that you don't have the same
experience and people who have grown up
under much tougher conditions um I mean
have an expanded experience in some ways
but we all have our traumas uh and we
all go through different things and in
that again this in this Humanity we
recognize each other um and out is about
Universal Humanity I think when it's
when it's good and so that's what we are
all seeking and that's why you know we
had also this great discussion Friday
about the work of everyone and I think
we do recognize each
other with the limitations of not having
the same experience of course yeah sure
I know it's kind of a banale question
but I will it anyway do you do you think
uh literature can change the world I
mean is it possible to do something
important with words who will say
something about
that
yes yeah literature already changed the
word
already without
literature imagine the world just
without literature where we would be uh
now
yeah I would like to share with you uh
yah I won't ask you anything just relax
uh but actually uh I think it's very
interesting that uh your your
Palestinian colleagues they think that
they can recognize the tone of your poet
poetry try to tell because for us it's
so brand new so could you please tell a
little about that maybe you could
because you were I think you were the
first who said something about
it
um I don't understand the word of Danish
but when I heard
Yahya read his
poetry I
felt uh the
surface of the
Poetry uh which communicates directly to
the
Danes uh communicated deeply within me
because I felt that his
voice came from my part of the world
from where I was
raised
uh the the
delivery uh of his uh of his
words
uh had something very deep down that is
very
connected uh with our
culture uh you know I did
mention forgot when I think yesterday or
before yester yesterday uh how in Arabic
we to the word
poem yeah called
cida uh which the in Spain they also use
it uh is based is rooted in the in the
verb meaning to
aim and the word Shar which means
poetry
uh comes from the root
of the verb to
feel so the writing of a poem in
Arabic is a combination of how you go
deep within you to aim out at
something and
interestingly is a feminine word and
Sh meaning feeling is a masculine word
so in a way the meeting of the two
words actually
represent what Arabic poetry is all
about and despite the
wall that I
sensed between the Poetry of Yahya and
myself uh I could feel the
river and where the source of that river
is it's very beautiful actually it's
very beautiful way of defining poetry
yeah I was I was actually thinking of
the need to have yah's poetry translated
into Arabic yeah and I've Speak I've
spoken with u Nan about that
possibility and to see
how uh I could uh encourage Nan to
exercise his past uh profession of a
journalist because there is something
very
important in the voice of
Yahya uh to be transmitted in the Arab
world how do you think it would be
perceived in the Arab world because here
we have some thought I I I I think it
will be received with with open arms
with open arms and and this is extremely
important for the Poetry of Yahya to
develop there is no way for it to
develop here we we know that he is even
physically
threatened to live in this country where
he was
raised and he has to at some point but
it is his
decision to go back to the roots of
where he comes
from and see the
connection that he is not
uprooted as he may be feeling in this
Society
very
good Nan you wanted to
comment I totally agree with Kamal and
he really draw my attention to um to
what I was personally feeling when when
I first saw reading I was looking at him
and saying oh my God I would be him if I
was writing in in Danish I would do the
same things um so as a voice as inner
voice I think he has a Palestinian Arab
uh voice and of course he's also Danish
by using the Danish language or by
belonging to the Danish language so he
has
both um uh within him of course like
most poets they do
uh
um misunderstood by
the by their side this is very common
among poets internationally there isn't
a good poet who wasn't Dam at least in
part of his life yeah if you would go
now and mention my name to people who
knew me 10 years ago or 15 years ago or
even now they would say he's horrible so
this is very common about poets but here
the Danish context is very sensitive for
reasons that y has nothing to do with so
the cont
the content sorry the context and the
media somehow they do hijacked his voice
and his story he's not the enemy of
Islam he's not ex Muslim he's not all
those labels he's just y so those labels
were imposed on him and I think it's
important to understand this I think
he's a wonderful person and I think he's
a a good voice for his uh society and
also for Denmark I think Denmark should
be proud of having such a beautiful
voice yeah you still don't want to say
anything
shukan means
what thank you you or what I said
thank you
okay what yeah well what to say I think
my my friends have articulated uh you
know his voice and what is
happening the attacks and so forth
reminds me I moved to New York right
after
911 and a lot of the uh Palestinian Arab
and Muslim poets uh especially uh those
that also had a similar because uh the
the the the voice of Yahya has that
Arabic I mean in Context but also you
know the the African-American tradition
and sort of the spoken word tradition
um also uh Echoes In His Voice for me
and a lot of Nan and I know some of them
but a lot of those poets um Muslim Arab
were heavily discriminated and the
Discrimination happens in different ways
sometimes it's not overt attacks but
they weren't given a space in which to
really publish the work now we do have
the internet where uh voices are able to
sort of trans send those borders that
you know uh that exist with Publishers
but it was unbelievable to me to to have
gone to the United States um to live for
the first time really uh after 9/11 and
realize the backlash that existed uh as
and you know among artists which is
normally uh a more open field
so integration
and of course um Danish Society is newer
at that because imagine the United
States it's a country of
immigrants so um but yes I think the
more we we we publish different voices
in a nation the more plural it is um the
more Beauty can
grow and J what do you think about this
whole thing about Yahya and the whole uh
reception in Denmark and the whole
debate and is is that we should be as
writers or why is it so Sensational in a
way um well in a strange way um I find
that it's very sad that when someone
writes some extraordinary poetry uh they
can get threatened on their life he
can't walk you know quietly in the
street at all um and then I think it's
up to the rest of us writers to help
stand up for him um and
I think uh it's very interesting what
Cal and also saying about that it would
be received very differently in in
Palestine I think it shows how much we
are a province here when it comes to
foreign
cultures um because I actually think the
same would be in in
America um and I have one question
for uh Camal here would nasan's poetry
in the Middle East be seen as a voice of
the Arab Spring you mean yeah sorry y
voice be seen as a voice for the Arab
Spring uh no I don't think so at all
yahya's
experience uh is U is a very specific
experience
dealing with
Denmark and with a certain uh accent of
Danish as I understand
stand uh I cannot see
it uh being compared neither to what
happened in in Black voices in
America or in the Arab world there is
something very
specific and poetry is always about the
detail of things it's a uh it's an the
elixir of language where you bring
something to the utmost
Essentials and you bring it out in the
language that uh is closest to your
lips this is what yah has done and
uh for me also the very name of
Yahya uh the root of that word
ISAT meaning
life and
Y has been always the first
word that was pronounced in every
Liberation
movement where you
say
and each person lives his name and Yahya
is living his name
in
Denmark that's that's may I just say
something and then um how I hear it in a
sense in the midst of these Autumn
storms we might be living a Danish
spring ladies and gentlemen I'm sorry
but the evening has come to an end I
would like uh to thank you very much you
have been the most inspiring thank you
for the importance of your work for all
of you you yeah also the Dan of course
for the beauty and for the creativity
you bringing and for um opening our
minds and for having been such good
company